uh i i maybe crazy's not the fair thing
to say your story to me is
unique from from you know i was an
athlete played at university colorado go
bus forget yeah longhorns
i was heavily recruited i almost went
you know when i was in school
there was a pipeline between between
california and colorado for sure they
were number three on my list
and uh one of my childhood idols rashaan
salaam went to
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah heisman
trophy yeah exactly same as you
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah they did a
lot of recruiting in southern
uh cali san diego la it used to be like
that used to be the mecca for cu
football and that's when we were good
yeah
and then they brought in a guy who was
like oh we need everybody good grades
and it just went
between i knew cu was in trouble when we
had white cornerbacks
yeah that's true yeah you have one but
when you got multiple yeah you know
both sides yeah
it's not good man yeah but the grades
were good but we sucked at football
but yeah i would say uh from an
athlete's perspective
i would say your story from an
outsider's view is heartbreaking
yeah interesting so which which part of
it
it's heartbreaking because right you're
a heisman trophy winner and won the best
football player
in college football of all time
university of texas you have all this
hype you get drafted in the first round
fifth pick
you're a baller in the nfl all pro led
the league in rushing which is insane
yeah but then the narrative on you is
now you know testing hot for marijuana
oh he's just recluse like he drifted
away it's like no
you guys pushed him away yeah and and
you're at the forefront of marijuana and
you know they want to push these opiates
and you know these these painkillers
which you know if you play any football
any major football whether it's college
or pro you know how
uh you know yeah opiates are the thing
that's pushed on you and they're not
good man opiates and nsaids too i had a
i had a ulcer at 19 from taking pop and
advil
yeah i had one from ibuprofen yeah yeah
and it but and it's just like so yeah
it's real and
for me it's like that's where it's
heartbreaking yeah where you were like
on the forefront where
if you were let's say you get drafted in
2021
yeah it's all good ricky's all good oh
wow he's such a smart guy so educated
and back then i was like no dude he's a
[ __ ] up yeah he he's he's this guy he's
caught in problems in the locker room
he's like
no no i just don't want to do your
opinions man like this isn't the move
yeah yeah you know it's not fair to say
or my outfit no no
you're right on and in a sense it's it's
heartbreaking but
but in the in the larger picture and i
think another good example is
is colin kaepernick where the truth is
as an athlete a professional athlete
you know your heyday is going to be
typically before you're 40.
yeah but in life in general your heyday
is when you're in your 50s correct and
so really
i look at at professional sports as as a
platform
and it's about what you do with that
platform and to me whether
you know whether you're on practice
squad and you make connections that's a
platform
or whether you're whether you're all pro
or hall of fame someone like tom brady
it's still just a platform yeah you know
and it's what do you do with that
platform and so i feel like
it was inadvertent i didn't think it
would revolve around cannabis but it did
that that would be my platform
to to do something bigger than just
score touchdowns
yeah i think now that that in the nfl no
player will be suspended for using
cannabis i feel like
yes it was heartbreaking but it helped
moved something forward that i
that i felt i feel responsible or at
least partially responsible one
dude or 100 you should yeah you're the
you're the rosa parks of that movement
yeah for a lack of better yeah and you
know i
i still got to 10 000 yards russian so i
feel like i did enough in the nfl and
that's what's heartbreaking to me it's
because your nfl career you were a
baller yeah with the narratives like oh
he was this problem
and marijuana testing hot all the time
it's like no all pro you dumbasses
yeah the story the story keeps going and
so to me i again
whatever you do in the nfl to me or as a
professional athlete
or even in your 20s and 30s it's a
platform for what you're going to do for
the rest of year
but but it's tough right and uh i i sent
this article to
to chin it's tough uh because uh i think
marcellus
bennett who played at texas a m i just
saw i just saw that and is he not
speaking fast he is
i read this one at 5am and i was fired
up like this dude
is dropping freaking knowledge and a lot
of athletes should read this
but the problem is is in the nfl it's
like
you know how it is like your whole life
when you're coming up in san diego being
the star running back
you know your life is football man so
it's like if you're not
focused on that sport and you know
rushing for
uh you know 2 000 yards in the nfl it's
hard to do anything else
it's like you have this short window to
make as much money and do as much as you
can
in pro sports so it's tough for these
guys to parlay into something else so
they get done
and as bennett was saying he's like you
get done man it's like
you got to start over yeah but you know
but to me there's a way to change that
like
we forget that our in our entree into
the nfl
is it you know at least three but up to
five years
in in college and the problem is you
know when i was growing up they would
say you got to have a plan b
you got to have a plan b plan b you know
it's for me it's not a plan b it's it's
realizing
you know if you do make it to the to the
league or whatever
what are you going to do with that and
so i think if guys use college to
to think about that and prepare
themselves you know thinking
okay i want to use this platform to do
so and so later in my life how can i use
this college experience
to gain to make connections to to take
classes that are going to help me later
on
so then while they're playing in the off
seasons and doing other things
they can keep work using those
connections and developing something
so when they're done playing football
it's not start over it's like a ramp
where you're taking it's
launching it's a launching pad and it
took me my first retirement in that year
off to to learn that
and then the last five years of my of my
career that's what i was doing and so
when i retired
you know i my goal was to to have an
indefinite nfl career where i got to
choose when i walked away
and so it got to the point where i had
so many other interests outside of
football
that you know it was a hard choice but i
i wanted to go do those things and i
felt like
i was sacrificing too much to keep
playing football yeah
it's weird too because i think gm's when
you go through the process of getting
draft and you interview with all the
gm's
if you're not hundred percent of
football they go out we don't know how
much he loves the game it's like
no i i love the game but i also love
this i love painting
i love hosting shows i like so i think
hopefully with the jams and the owners
of the teams
they realize guys can do a bunch of
different things look at michael strahan
well i think the players have to set
that precedent you know because it's the
same thing but to me
looking back i say i'd rather take less
money but go to a team in a situation
that understands me and who i am yeah
because it's going to improve the
quality of my life
and to me longevity and meaningful
longevity in any sport comes from
quality of life
agree yeah 100 yeah because i think too
you know if you're not completely
committed to football
you're getting not only backlash from
the gm and the owners of the team but
the fan base too
so if you're out doing you know doing
your stuff and in the ufc the narratives
change i don't know how much you follow
the ufc but in the ufc there's guys like
daniel cormier
there's uh other guys tyrone woodley
who they're doing a ton of things but
there's you know he
dc's retired now but he was a
commentator yeah you know he was doing
all this other stuff he had his gym
he has this foundation you know
woodley's a rapper he's hosting a show
on tmz
and he's still defending the title at
the time a lot of people like oh we
don't know how much he's into it yeah
but then when these guys are winning
it's like oh you
you can't exactly exactly yeah exactly
and i think as
you know we the image of the renaissance
man as a
as a as a professional athlete as that
starts to become more popular you're
gonna you're gonna see more of that
because you know for me at the core of
it i went back to school after i after i
retired and i took this class on the
history of sport
and so back in 1906 uh president
roosevelt called a conference at the
white house
at the white house to save football
because there have been six deaths in
football that year and colleges were
talking about shutting it down and he
said you know we have
wars coming in the future and we need
something to help prepare leaders
and so at the core of the football
tradition in this country
is about preparing men to be leaders and
so i see i see football
and you know this that environment and
what you learn the skills
how to deal with adversity how to work
together as a team how to stay focused
how to train
how to buy into a philosophy yeah all
those things
equip us to be successful in anything in
life where we can apply those
principles how about that when i get off
stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son